ربما لديهم التقارير
ورأى أن المشاركات الإسرائيلية
هذا الأسبوع التخطيط لعدة
ألف وحدة سكنية في القوانين
الضفة الغربية تريد دفع ذلك
هي مناسبة للحكومة الفيدرالية
الشغل الشاغل لموقفنا و
كما تعلمون، لدينا بالفعل هنا
يتكرر في كثير من الأحيان واضح
والمستوطنات غير قانونية بموجب القانون الدولي
ويعرض للخطر اثنين في المستقبل
حل الدولة لدينا هذا أيضا
المحادثات الأخيرة مع الإسرائيليين
الحكومة سواء من حيث المبدأ أو
فيما يتعلق بهذه المشاريع المحددة
موجهة بشكل واضح جدا
وبالإضافة إلى ذلك، لدينا القرار
لاحظت أن الإضافية
الوزير في
وزارة الدفاع motrich
السيطرة على
عملية تخطيط تسوية النقل
هل سنصبح القانون الدولي؟
الآثار المترتبة على هذه القرارات
التحقق من التنسيق مع الشركاء بعناية
ارتفاع عدد الوفيات أيضا من
المدنيين والقاصرين في
الأسابيع والأشهر الماضية تملأنا
بقلق بالغ على حماية
وينبغي للمجتمع المدني أن يأتي دائما في المقام الأول
الظروف الدقيقة لل
مهندس حادث اليوم نحن
لم يعرف بعد ولكن واضح
في وضع متوتر للغاية
التناسب يأتي دائما في المقام الأول
العطاء هو